ce matin le quartier saint-jacques
semble retrouver sa tranquillité
l'annoncé de l'arrestation hier soir des
deux auteurs présumés de la fusillade
est reçu comme un soulagement par les
habitants non mais pour les victimes
parce que comme ça au moins la justice
va être fait et puis que le calme va
être dans le quartier parce que on est
fille beaucoup ici les victimes sont
toujours hanté par les images de
l'agression elle préfère ne pas
témoigner à visage découvert mais depuis
la nuit dernière
elles ont retrouvé un peu de sérénité
enfin la vérité elle apparaît ça fait du
bien
maintenant on espère juste qu'ils ça va
servir d'exemple parce que ce qui s'est
passé
on veut vraiment un signal et c'était
très grave faut qu'ils paient pour ce
qu'ils ont fait puisque c'est quand je
vous ai dit c'est parce ça on voit ça
dans les films et même dans les films on
a peur alors imaginez si vous l'avez vu
en vrai cette jeune femme de 20 ans a
été blessé dans la fusillade du 29
juillet tout sépare quarante trois
impacts de plombs au delà des
arrestations
elle est satisfait de la qualification
des faits par le procureur tentative
d'assassinât aggravée par trois
circonstances dont la motivation raciste
du passage à l'acte
oui c'est important au début je ne
faisais que c'était une règle un
règlement de comptes mais pas du tout
enfin ils ont compris que c'est un
raciste un truc race donc oui ça fait
aussi plaisir parce que je comprends les
banques prétextant règlement con pour
permettre l'identification des suspects
d'importants moyens avaient été mis en
oeuvre jusqu'à une quarantaine de
policiers et une vingtaine de gendarmes
il fallait évidemment réagir vite et
efficacement donc c'est ce sont des
faits graves mais sur le parquet a pris
toute la mesure de ces faits belga les
auteurs présumés seraient originaires de
dijon est âgé d'une trentaine d'années
ils sont actuellement toujours en garde
à vue